Hello there, you've just joined us deep
in the Amazon Rainforest.
Sweaty.
Very hot.
Uh, we've found...
some Sony speakers, in
their natural habitat...
Just lying around.
Which is why we came to the rainforest.
What are we doing today?
Uh, we've got some food today.
We're gonna make some,
using the corn starch we've got.
Found this in the jungle over there.
Oh, it's getting bright
let me adjust the exposure.
You keep going.
And...
And we also found a Sony Hi-Fi system.
We're gonna hookup the Sony speakers to it
and hopefully get that whole...
There's the speaker.
Yeah.
Get at it!
Just pull the whole top
off... there you go.
That is a weird feeling!
Isn't that weird?
Weird! Have you done this before?
Yeah.
So after many years of filming
with either very bright
lights or indirect sunlight,
I've learnt that filming in
slow-mo with the color white
is an absolute nightmare.
So now it's not. It's a--
Oh that looks better.
It's red.
All right we have to
mix this in really well.
Ah, that looks weird!
That good?
Yeah.
Yeah?
That's so weird!
It's not liquid at all, look!
Feels like... ah so strange.
That's me trying to put as
much as I can on my hands.
It just locks up,
it's like "no I don't want to leave!"
Oh man!
All right that's probably enough.
You reckon?
That might be too much actually.
Okay so...
Are you ready?
Yeah, ready.
Go for it!
All right, now stop it!
So weird, isn't it!
Yeah, it's really weird!
Like once you set it off it's like...
Oh there you go!
And then it just collapses
back into liquid afterwards.
Yeah.
Well, thanks for watching that video!
Be sure to follow us on Twitter,
take a gander at the
T-shirts, we've got three.
Uh, that's about it really...
Subscribe!
My eyebrows are actually
the sweat out from my eyes.
I think that is indeed
the purpose of eyebrows.
Evolution!
Yeah.
Right, well I'm gonna get
something from the fridge.
Yeah, uh...
Play some Xbox or something?
Yeah.
Still haven't finished Dead Rising.